sadly unavoidable right I hear all this  and I'm saying to myself how fortunate  it was to grow up in the 80s yeah and  party like a rock star my biggest worry  was like where was the party that week  and where we're gonna go get a cold keg  of Budweiser oh even then that and the  90s it was just so incredible and I see  these kids now and it's such a  difference you know they're glued to the  phones glued to the cell phone we're all  having addiction with it you know and  it's just so much different than when I  grew up and you know we went on beer  runs in high school and we just had a  good time and we didn't have all you'd  ever heard of a school shooting yeah  that's just horrible